[Música]
o dia
meu nome é dedic de moraes dantas tem 10
anos e hoje vim falar sobre gentileza
com a natureza
eu escolhi esse tema pois gosto muito de
animais e me preocupo muito com os maus
tratos e agressões sofridas por eles
vamos assistir ao vídeo
eu sou amazônia a maior floresta
tropical do mundo
eu mando chuva quando vocês precisam
eu mantenho seu clima estável
em minhas florestas
existem plantas que curam suas doenças
muitas delas vocês ainda nem descobriram
mas vocês estão tirando tudo de mim a
cada segundo vocês cortam uma das minhas
árvores enchem de sujeira os meus rios
colocam fogo em mim e eu não posso mas
proteger as pessoas que vivem aqui
quanto mais vocês tiram - eu tenho para
oferecer menos água menos escuras menos
oxigênio
[Música]
se eu morrer vocês também mãe
mas eu prefiro de mim
[Música]
e esta foi a floresta amazônica falando
com a gente
a natureza não precisa da gente mas nós
precisamos dela
vamos comparar natureza viva a natureza
morta
no princípio o homem do saber fazer
tanto mal à natureza
mas agora que nós temos essa consciência
não podemos deixar que isso continue
acontecendo aqui estão alguns nomes de
ambos que ajuda no reflorestamento que
são plante árvore
ss mata atlântica e se ativa verde
aqui é só citei 3 mas existem várias
outras ongs
vamos comparar animais em um mundo sem
poluição e animais em um mundo com
poluição uso dos animais também são
muito afetados pela poluição de rios e
mares contrabando
você já ouviu falar os animais
silvestres alguns são capturados e
vendidos
a maioria deles é filhotes e
infelizmente alguns morrem no meio do
caminho não venda não com quem denuncie
não prenda e ajude ainda algumas pessoas
que não ajudam que não pensou antes de
comprar os animais
então quando não querem mais eles os
largam no meio da rua 11 que ajuda os
animais que são wwf e obama
chico mendes e projeto tamar concluindo
o meu projeto eu realmente acredito que
é possível fazer a diferença fazendo a
nossa parte que é denunciar e ajudar
se uma pessoa já faz a diferença imagine
todos nós juntos um dia vamos começar
hoje estou distribuindo mudas de plantas
para quem quiser plantar muito obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]